okay Bob this next section this next
division of Isaiah that we're looking at
in chapters 34 to 39 really rounds off
the part of Isaiah leading right up to
what's traditionally been the corpus of
second Isaiah and chapters 40 to 55 so
we're dealing with a set of chapters
that is really right before this
material about the liberation from exile
the return home all of that it contains
some very powerful poetry some of it
disturbing there in chapter 34 there's
this divine judgment against nations
particularly Edom
can you just reflect a little bit about
what your reading of this what what
prompts a judgment on the nation's what
props are concerned with Edom what's
what's this all about that's a very
difficult question and I'm not sure I
have a good answer to it it is a section
that for the first time in the material
we've looked at calls attention to the
role of the nation's visa avi Israel in
this plan that God seems to have worked
out and we'll hear more and more about
this plan and more and more probably
about the role of the nations in it it's
important to look at where this falls
chapter xxxiv which is an outright
judgment against all the nations that
are being summoned because god has
planned a judgment for them it's not
clear what they have done but by
extension they seem to be associating
the nations with Assyria that had
unsuccessfully besieged Jerusalem the
immediately preceding chapter in chapter
33 is in fact a liturgical celebration
of the salvation of Jerusalem during the
Assyrian invasion of 701 we have not yet
heard that story in Isaiah we have seen
some Oracle's that refer to it but we
have not yet actually gotten a narrative
of it so we are in a way celebrating the
event liturgically in chapter 3
without knowing any details yet of what
that is going to be and then suddenly
and unexpectedly here come all of the
nations for judgment as if the nations
themselves represent all opposing powers
against Jerusalem that will focus almost
immediately on Edom as representative of
Nations and therefore Edom is going to
undergo this terrible judgment what's
going on with that verse 6 you've got
Basra Edom
chapter 34 wife who is Edom and why
single them out there is a historical
answer for that probably which has
absolutely nothing as far as we know to
do with the Assyrian crisis itself
Edom was not involved as far as we know
in the Assyrian crisis but they were
involved much later when it was not the
Assyrians but the Babylonians and it was
the Babylonians who captured Jerusalem
invaded it deported population in the
Babylonia pier which is much later than
the Assyrian period and the then
decisively destroyed Jerusalem so it's
eventually getting back at Edom for
pangas after that the [ __ ] made a
land grab against Judah and tried to
recapture territory and the Israelites
never forgot it one of the reasons in
the New Testament period that the
population of Judea did not like Herod
was he was an ignominious a descendant
of the [ __ ] they they had a very
long memory about what the [ __ ] did
that's undoubtedly the reason they
choose Edom so this is probably material
from second Isaiah it's material that
presupposes these events of deportation
of captivity that Israel underwent and
this is just retribution they think
against Edom but here there's none of
that you don't have any indication of
historical context they're generalizing
this and Edom now is simply a symbol
of other nations but you better be my
next question is this really just about
those awful historical events were
eating how precisely not that yeah and
that's a peculiarity of this chapter
it's followed immediately in chapter 35
by material that sounds very much like
the second Isaiah in verse 8 it's
talking about the desert blooming at the
beginning of the chapter it's talking
about bringing the people back in
chapter in verse 8 it's talking about a
highway we're gonna see all this
language recur again in chapter 40 which
is the beginning normally of what people
think of as the second Isaiah material
highway is really the route home from
exits the room for Mexico what God is
doing that's right it's the route home
from exile and so what these two
chapters seem to be doing together is
providing you with a kind of generalized
notion of if you go back all the way to
chapter 33 of the salvation of Israel
followed by judgment against the nations
followed by salvation again for Israel
but now in very general terms it really
is kind of a cyclic allure isolating it
matters to be setting up a an
oscillation between judgment and promise
that they think of as characteristic of
Israel's life with God and you can now
track this in general terms it's setting
up almost a paradigm against which all
the rest of the material is looked at
but it's not a random pattern it really
sells really is hard as a lighting
pattern and and God is at work in this
pattern and I think that's well out of
what second I guess theology is doing is
really trying to make sure that there
there is a divine movement of God's Word
through all that survives and you see it
very clearly in what immediately follows
which is the specific story about the
7:01 crisis for the first time now we
finally get the historical narrative
leave we had it referred to over and
over it's presupposed at places finally
they're going to tell us what it's about
and it deals with the miraculous
deliverance of Jerusalem yes during the
invasion of Sennacherib and prominent in
it is this Oracle from Isaiah which is
quoted within the context of the
narrative and it appears in chapter 37
it's an article of deliverance for
Jerusalem and ultimately of punishment
for Sennacherib for attacking the city
but the most interesting words a
beginning in verse 26 have you not known
have you not heard what I did that I
determined it long ago I planned from
days of old what I now bring to pass and
this is God speaking this is a
long-range plan it's a long trajectory
yes referring to previous prophecies but
now all part of some kind of a divine
plan and to go back to this oscillation
that we saw in chapters 34 35 one begins
to get the sense that somehow this is
all part of God's plan I mean this God
of second Isaiah is the Holy One of
Israel just God the tower is outside of
the cosmos and that can see the
direction of history and trying to get
human beings to get with the flow of
where the word is is moving where God is
and what God is doing at the moment all
of this will become a major issue for
later generations as they try to
interpret this including our own because
the notion of a predetermined plan to
history whether it leads to judgment or
salvation all somehow determined in
advance is an idea that we have enormous
problems with but I do want to ask you
about the way this narrative ends in
chapter 39 is very strange story about
Hezekiah entertaining the Babylonian
messengers and this calling forth from
Isaiah a judgment oracle against the
king and the dynasty and the city
interpret isn't sick in their heads and
spelled jar after jar think over chapter
39 because
Hezekiah does this stupid act these
emissaries from Babylon come and ask to
see his house and he shows them the
Royal belongings and Isaiah comes and
says because you've shown all these
belongings they're all going to be
lugged off to Babylon well how can the
whole Babylonian exile be dude just to a
stupid act of the King who wasn't
thinking I think the reason that the
story is here and what many interpreters
have have missed is that's precisely the
point it can't be just because King
Hezekiah showed his furniture to these
emissaries he showed all of the
furniture and all of its going to be
lugged away that's setting you up for
the certainty of the Exile but it's all
part of God's plan from the beginning
God was determined to create this
remnant and to bring them through this
crisis and that's what God's Word is
going to accomplish and when Hezekiah
says at the end of chapter 39 which you
have what the word of the Lord which you
have spoken is good I think that's
recognizing the word of the Lord it's
it's going to happen I've gotta live
into it and there isn't anything much
anybody can do about that that's the
thing we're gonna run into again in
chapter 40 now how does this set us up
for this material in chapter 40
following it highlights again one of
these characteristic themes of Isaiah
that the word the divine were given by
the Prophet he is going to be fulfilled
and there's no way to avoid that so once
this has been given the Exile becomes an
immediate reality the exile in Babylon
is an immediate reality and the last
words of that chapter prepare us for the
beginning of the period of the return
the Exile itself is lost in the space
between chapters 39 and chapter 40